um check this out
always always mean what you say
real [ __ ] till i leave elevated do this
rapping [ __ ] with ease i got a brick on
my sleeve you dissing me please
comparing me to different emcees stop it
i really am okay so he said you're
dissing me and
i know a thing or two about dissing when
i was younger that was like yo mama
jokes like yo mama so fat whatever um
in 2021 that looks like
i'm i'm a [ __ ] your girl i would think
yeah that's my guess this [ __ ] still
won't pop it before twitter was a
trending topic i was on the block with
30 shots and glocks had the spot hopping
dummy but they acting like they don't
remember that been a leader with that
heater i got right up into that you
can't never take a killing back whole
heart was in the street okay so he's
saying you can never take a kill and
back so if you kill somebody you can't
take that back i think that's pretty
self-explanatory but
like i think i could have inferred that
without it being a rap but you know
that's just me i had to leave and get my
[ __ ] feelings back same spot they
shot my brother next day i'm chilling it
i ain't lying they was winning till we
started spinning backs but anyway said
enough of that let's talk about this
paper about it let's talk about them
jets yeah let's talk about jamaica asked
about me i ain't never been a fraud i
went hard from the start in my city i'm
a god [ __ ] if you know you know
never been no phony though rollies for
my brody though so he's saying i've
never been a phony and that basically
means that i'm not fake i tell it to you
how it is
barely no joe rodeo heard they looking
for me i'm like oh i'm on the way buying
money no i'm straight i spent 130 k out
the gate they like swerve stay safe i'm
like oh my gosh i love this beat i love
it this beat is fun i can already see
y'all late yelling creamy i'm like i've
been in the crib all day i'm in cali
thinking
[Music]
hey i like his outfit black on black i
think it's cool
but they taught me not to show that
before that like a throwback as soon as
this [ __ ] go
[Music]
okay so i he said i could have bought a
rolls royce which is a car i think
um
and
instead he bought a four flat so is that
like a apartment like a flat
chicago i'm pro
motivation for the trenches cause i'm
pro black real no limit so we don't play
by the rules how the [ __ ] i catch a case
we bought a school don't be fooled you
[ __ ] fools
on the ground reading comments i'm like
oh cool so they want me to lose i can't
break like i'm bulletproof
okay they always say this
in raps they're like they want me to
lose
but i guarantee nobody cares about you
that much like i'm sure some people
don't like you and aren't excited when
you do well but nobody's sitting around
just like
pray what do they say praying on your
downfall
yeah and i can't say what i won't say
all i'm gonna say is before fame [ __ ]
i've been the truth and when you put it
on my name you gotta send some proof
they like charge it to the game i got
feelings too should be difficult
still visual it is me and jb just been
talking about residuals
[Music]
coming soon
[Music]
and we get airplanes next year [ __ ]
show i've been shopping for him
an airplane what the hell we're going to
demand next year too to get all diamonds
[Music]
huh
okay well